Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Cominciamo con una domanda
apparentemente semplice.
Chi di voi, in questo momento,
crede di star sognando?
Alzi la mano: ne abbiamo uno, due.
Non tanti, per fortuna.
(Risate)
Una seconda domanda collegata alla prima,
anche se apparentemente non lo è:
chi di voi si fiderebbe di qualcuno
che vi tradisce ogni giorno?
Ogni giorno, anzi ogni notte, vi inganna,
facendovi credere cose che non sono vere.
C'è qualcuno che si fiderebbe?
No: su questo, siamo tutti coerenti.
Eppure, questo è quello che facciamo:
fidarci di qualcuno
che ci inganna tutti i giorni.
È quello che facciamo tutti noi,
perché siamo ingannati dalla nostra mente
ogni giorno, ogni notte quando dormiamo,
per mediamente un'ora e mezza.
Questa è la durata
delle cosiddette fasi REM,
quella in cui noi sogniamo
mentre dormiamo.
Qual è l'esperienza del sogno?
Lo sappiamo tutti:
crediamo a quello che vediamo.
Se siamo in un incubo abbiamo paura,
perché quel mostro che ci insegue
crediamo che sia vero.
Se abbiamo un "affaire"
con qualcuno, ci crediamo.
E quella esperienza che viviamo,
la viviamo intensamente.
La nostra mente ci inganna
in una maniera estremamente convincente,
che coinvolge tutti i nostri sensi.
Coinvolge la vista, coinvolge l'udito,
coinvolge il tatto, coinvolge le emozioni.
Il nostro cervello e la nostra mente
producono per noi, quando sogniamo,
delle specie di film,
di realtà virtuali naturali.
Qualcuno di voi avrà cominciato
ad utilizzare la realtà virtuale, no?
Cosa succede? Siamo immersi, ci crediamo.
Nel sogno, ancora di più.
Abbiamo una tecnologia,
diciamo, "naturale" ancora più efficace.
Eppure, durante la giornata,
quando siamo svegli,
ci fidiamo della nostra mente,
che è la stessa
che ci ha tradito nella notte,
è la stessa che ci ha ingannato -
o che magari ci ha ispirato,
durante la notte,
ma pur sempre generando
qualcosa che non è vero.
È costruito, è illusorio, è un'ombra.
Vedete, questa idea
che la nostra mente ci inganna
ha attraversato tutta la nostra
cultura occidentale
in una maniera molto profonda
generando due approcci,
due modi di pensiero,
estremamente importanti per tutti noi.
Non potremmo essere qui adesso,
se non avessimo posto in dubbio
la natura ingannatrice dei nostri sensi.
Una di queste discipline è la scienza.
Con il metodo scientifico,
la scienza intende andare
oltre i limiti della mente individuale,
l'inganno dei nostri sensi.
È per quello che usiamo un metro.
Se io ad occhio dico che quella cosa
è lunga un metro e mezzo,
so che posso ingannarmi;
la mia mente non è precisa,
ho bisogno di usare uno strumento
che dia una misura oggettiva
di quella lunghezza.
E così è per tutto,
nell'ambito scientifico.
Noi formuliamo dei modelli:
ma non ci fidiamo,
dobbiamo fare degli esperimenti,
dobbiamo prendere delle misure
per far sì che quella nostra idea,
quella nostra fantasia
venga in qualche modo confermata
dalla realtà esterna.
Quindi il metodo scientifico
ha ben presente
che la nostra mente ci inganna.
E non conta il parere
di un singolo scienziato,
perché quello lì magari si sarà sbagliato,
avrà fatto degli esperimenti, diciamo,
solo in una certa direzione;
ha bisogno dell'altro scienziato,
o dell'altra scienziata,
che metta in discussione,
cerchi di falsificare
quello che il primo scienziato,
o la prima scienziata, aveva formulato.
Un altro approccio
che fortemente tiene conto
della natura ingannatrice dei nostri sensi
è la filosofia occidentale.
C'è anche quella orientale,
ma abbiamo più familiarità
con quella occidentale.
Pensate a Cartesio, René Descartes:
grande filosofo francese,
uno dei padri del pensiero moderno.
Lui parte nel suo studio filosofico,
nella sua esplorazione filosofica,
proprio dal dubbio fondante
sulla veridicità dei suoi sensi.
E cerca di trovare un punto solido
al di qua dei sensi
su cui poi dopo poter costruire
un sistema filosofico,
e quindi lui parte
con il "cogito ergo sum",
famosissimo.
Vedete, scienza e filosofia,
e vari approcci filosofici
che adesso non esploriamo,
hanno ben presente
la natura illusoria dei nostri sensi.
Ma noi, come individui,
poche volte ci chiediamo,
durante il giorno:
"Sto sognando oppure no?"
E invece crediamo a quello
che i nostri sensi, costantemente,
ci fanno vedere, sentire,
ascoltare, toccare.
Vorrei però sottolineare con voi, adesso,
un particolare metodo
che noi possiamo utilizzare
per diventare più consapevoli
della natura incantatrice
dei nostri sensi.
E questo avviene proprio mentre sogniamo.
Cioè, mentre siamo
in un sogno normale,
cercare di coltivare la capacità
di chiedersi se quello
sia un sogno oppure no.
Cioè, io sono per esempio, inseguito
da questo mostro di un incubo;
e mentre sto scappando,
mi fermo, contemplo la situazione
e chiedo: ma questo è un sogno oppure no?
E mi giro verso il mostro.
È un passaggio di coscienza
estremamente difficile, non è facile;
però, forse, qualcuno di voi
ne avrà avuto esperienza.
Qualcuno di voi, forse,
avrà fatto un sogno
in cui sente che è un sogno
e forse riesce un pochino a dirigerlo.
Si tratta di sogni pre-lucidi.
Il sogno lucido è un'esperienza
estremamente intensa,
in cui noi siamo pienamente consapevoli
del fatto che ci troviamo in un sogno.
Vedete, questa esperienza
a me è capitata da adolescente,
perché un po' praticavo, maldestramente,
tecniche di meditazione
durante il giorno.
E una notte mi è capitato
di fare un sogno lucido di questo tipo,
estremamente intenso,
che mi ha un po' trasformato, diciamo,
nel modo in cui io vedevo,
e in cui ancora oggi vedo,
la coscienza e la consapevolezza.
Quel primo sogno poi,
immediatamente riportato
sull'agenda dei sogni lucidi,
ha costituito il primo passo
di centinaia e centinaia di sogni lucidi
che ho fatto nella mia vita,
e continuo ancora a fare.
E che hanno un grosso
potere trasformativo.
Inizialmente, con i primi sogni
si impara un po' a giocare.
Una cosa per esempio che facevo
era di alzarmi
qualche centimetro da terra.
Quindi cercare di sfidare
le leggi della fisica,
e spostarmi da un luogo all'altro
di questa realtà onirica,
estremamente dettagliata, scivolando.
Ma poi, perché fermarsi a quello?
Quindi nei sogni successivi
mi alzavo di più,
e passavo anche attraverso le pareti.
Avevo la possibilità
di volare sopra la città,
la possibilità di andare
da una città ad un'altra,
sempre con estremo realismo.
Incontrare persone che il nostro
mondo onirico genera per noi -
le persone del sogno
non le possiamo controllare,
sono dotate di una strana
indipendenza di pensiero;
ma noi possiamo decidere
di andare da loro.
Possiamo trasformare il nostro corpo,
perché ci si ritrova
con un corpo di sogno,
che è quello tipico della veglia.
Ma se noi guardiamo
le nostre mani di sogno,
possiamo, con uno sforzo
di lucidità e di consapevolezza,
trasformarle: sei dita o dieci dita,
o le mani di un animale,
diventare un lupo.
E possibile diventare un'aquila:
non solo volare, ma anche
avere il corpo di un'aquila.
È possibile trasformarsi in un cane,
in una donna se siete un uomo,
in un uomo se siete una donna.
È possibile stare
in due posti contemporaneamente,
essere cosciente di essere in due luoghi -
e perché no, anche tre luoghi.
A me è capitato, una volta,
di essere in tre luoghi diversi:
in uno stavo volando,
nell'altro camminavo
e nell'altro ero fuso con un pavimento.
Non è stato tanto piacevole,
ma interessante.
In ogni caso, voi siete in controllo:
potete svegliarvi in qualsiasi momento.
Ecco, dicevamo della filosofia.
Ci sono varie tracce di questa capacità
della nostra consapevolezza
di spostarsi nel mondo delle ombre.
Uno dei miti che più rende questa idea,
è un famosissimo mito,
che sono certo molti di voi
avrete sentito o studiato:
Il mito della caverna di Platone,
l'allegoria anche della caverna,
viene chiamata anche così.
Ed è questa storia che, sintetizzo,
scritta da Platone
2.400 anni fa, nella Repubblica,
in cui siamo in una grotta
nelle profondità della terra.
E ci sono dei prigionieri incatenati
che sono costretti a guardare
solo sul fondo della caverna.
Non hanno la possibilità
di spostarsi e guardarsi indietro.
Quello è il loro mondo.
Dietro di loro, a loro insaputa,
c'è un enorme fuoco,
e tra il fuoco e i prigionieri
ci sono delle persone
che passano con degli oggetti.
Quindi i prigionieri vedono,
sul fondo della caverna,
delle ombre che si spostano.
Quella è la loro realtà:
e credono, quindi,
che quella sia tutta la realtà.
Quelle ombre sono tutto ciò che c'è.
Un giorno succede
che uno di questi prigionieri
viene liberato dalle catene.
Si ritrova a poter uscire
da quel suo mondo limitato.
La prima cosa che fa
è vedere che c'è un enorme fuoco,
e vede che ci sono
degli oggetti tridimensionali
di cui prima non aveva assolutamente idea.
E capisce che le ombre,
che prima pensava essere
gli oggetti del mondo,
sono solo una proiezione della realtà
degli oggetti tridimensionali.
Poi, in lontananza, vede una luce
che è l'ingresso nella caverna
in cui aveva vissuto fino ad allora.
Vi si dirige, esce fuori
e vede che il mondo
è molto più complesso:
è molto ricco, pieno
di colori, pieno di luce;
e c'è un grande fuoco,
molto più grande di quello della caverna,
che è il sole, che illumina
tutti gli oggetti;
e con questi può interagire,
può correre, può toccare le cose.
Così risvegliato - questa, vedete,
è una metafora del risveglio -
però fa un altro passaggio,
che è quello che avviene, anche,
nel sogno lucido;
dal risveglio, decide di tornare
nel Mondo delle Ombre.
Ritorna giù nella grotta,
dove ci sono i suoi compagni
ancora prigionieri.
E vuole con essi comunicare
che la realtà delle ombre
non è la vera realtà.
Ma c'è una realtà molto più complessa,
molto più ricca, molto più bella,
molto più vera, esterna.
Vedete i miti, sapete,
descrivono dei processi mentali,
così come i sogni.
Infatti miti e sogni si sovrappongono,
hanno uno stretto legame.
In questo mito di Platone
c'è questo movimento mentale
del risvegliarsi.
Un processo duro,
anche perché all'inizio
è difficile svegliarsi,
perché siamo accecati dalla luce;
ma poi, pian piano,
ci svegliamo completamente.
Ma poi, vedete,
c'è questo secondo passaggio,
che è il ritorno al mondo delle ombre:
il ritorno al sonno,
il ritorno alla condizione illusoria
in cui si cerca di interagire,
ma da risvegliato.
Quindi, vedete,
come svegliarsi, ma nel sogno.
La ricerca neuroscientifica,
negli ultimi anni,
si è concentrata su questo fenomeno.
Prima era, appunto,
più appannaggio della filosofia,
o di qualche aneddoto raccontato qua e là.
Poi è diventato uno studio
della psicologia;
e adesso, addirittura,
anche delle neuroscienze.
Quindi, cosa succede in un cervello
che sta sognando lucidamente?
Il messaggio è questo:
noi abbiamo una parte del cervello
che è molto importante,
che si chiama corteccia prefrontale -
è quella che abbiamo dietro la fronte.
Potete immaginare il suo ruolo
come quello di direttore d'orchestra
di tutte le nostre capacità mentali.
È quella che dirige la visione,
che decide quando dobbiamo
prestare attenzione,
a cosa dobbiamo prestare attenzione
nel nostro campo visivo.
Quindi il direttore d'orchestra,
nel senso che non suona
uno strumento di per sé,
ma regola, diciamo,le produzioni
di tutti gli altri strumenti.
È quindi un po' il boss -
o la boss - della nostra mente.
Ecco quando noi facciamo
dei sogni normali, ordinari,
la corteccia prefrontale è spenta,
mentre tutto il resto del cervello
è normalmente attivo,
quasi come se fossimo svegli.
Quindi un cervello molto attivo,
tranne che per la corteccia prefrontale.
Quello che si è scoperto
è che quando facciamo un sogno lucido -
evento rarissimo, difficilissimo
da studiare nei laboratori,
la corteccia prefrontale
comincia a essere attiva.
Non pienamente, come se fossimo svegli;
ma in molte parti sostanziali
è più attiva, consuma più ossigeno.
Si è anche visto
che chi ha più propensione
per il sogno lucido,
o ha sviluppato questa capacità
di essere cosciente nei suoi sogni,
ha una corteccia prefrontale
più doppia, più spessa,
lo possiamo misurare
con risonanze magnetiche,
a indicare quindi
una maggiore predisposizione
a essere il direttore d'orchestra attivo,
ad avere un direttore d'orchestra
attivo nella propria mente.
Tanti studi - e tantissimi
sono ancora in corso,
è un argomento di ricerca
estremamente recente.
La corteccia prefrontale
è il mio argomento di ricerca preferito,
quindi da tanti anni mi occupo
di come la corteccia prefrontale
regola e dirige il nostro comportamento.
Allora cosa possiamo fare,
se vogliamo aumentare
questa nostra capacità
di essere coscienti nel sogno?
Una delle tecniche è proprio
quella di chiedersi, anche da svegli,
se stiamo sognando oppure no.
Così, improvvisamente:
"Sto sognando oppure no?"
Più che darsi una risposta,
porsi la domanda,
mettere un po' il dubbio
sul fatto che quello che stiamo vedendo
sia la realtà oppure no.
Se sia una nostra proiezione
oppure è un dato di fatto oggettivo.
Farlo più volte, durante il giorno,
ci fa incorporare una sorta di abitudine.
Per cui potrebbe darsi che,
una di queste volte che ce lo chiediamo,
in realtà stiamo sognando realmente.
Per cui sto parlando con qualcuno
nel mio mondo di sogno,
e mi fermo un attimo, dicendo:
sto realmente parlando con questa persona,
sto realmente guardando un TED Talk,
oppure è un sogno?
E cercare di porsi una risposta valida.
Facendo questo più volte,
durante la giornata;
ma non per rifugiarsi
in un mondo di sogno, attenzione!
È esattamente il movimento opposto,
è per diventare più pienamente
consapevoli, lucidi e presenti
in quello che stiamo esperendo.
Facendo così, possiamo diventare
dei sognatori lucidi esperti.
E che vantaggio ne abbiamo,
nella nostra vita da svegli?
Pensate a una situazione in cui
c'è un evento negativo che vi accade:
non so, siete licenziati.
Brutto, oggettivamente brutto:
ma quanta proiezione di negatività c'è,
su un evento così oggettivamente brutto?
Incominciamo ad autosvalutarci:
"Perché hanno licenziato me?"
"Non meritavo di avere quella posizione";
"Non ho mai mostrato di essere bravo
su quello o su quell'altro";
"Non ho più possibilità";
"Cosa penseranno di me i miei familiari?"
Tutto questo, vedete, è come un sogno:
è un vestito di sogno
che noi mettiamo addosso
ai fatti reali e concreti.
Allenarsi a sognare lucidamente
aiuta a distinguere ciò che è fatto
da ciò che è nostra proiezione.
In questo modo possiamo vivere meglio,
non per rifugiarci in un mondo distante
ma per essere più presenti nei fatti.
E quindi diventare più simili
al prigioniero liberato
della caverna di Platone
e poter andare in giro,
fuori nel mondo esterno,
illuminato dal sole,
o anche ritornare nel mondo delle ombre
senza lasciarci catturare da queste.
Quindi vi saluto con un augurio
di buon risveglio nei sogni.
(Applausi)